good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast we are live back in
New York City who I mean I'm happy to be
back live back in New York City but I
really do miss LA my second home ya know
we spent the weekend in LA home away
from home
it was we actually didn't even spend the
weekend we spend literally two days but
it was so lovely we stayed at the Four
Seasons which is just what a spectacular
hotel I mean not as really not as good
as the five seasons that they stay at in
Riverdale but pretty close pretty just
one season off pretty close la was just
so fabulous you guys we talk a big game
about LA on the show and we went there
for no more than 48 hours not an hour
more it was good I feel like I did in 48
hours in LA what I normally do in a week
in New York yeah more more if you missed
our episode on Friday we kept our
fabulous night out in Los Angeles we the
next day went to Noemi Malibu that was
just spectacular
it really was it was so beautiful LA
it's just like you get the city and then
you get the beach you must get the
sunset because you're on the west coast
when we were driving down PCH as the
locals call it
it was our dinner reservation was at 6
o'clock so it was about like about 5:45
and it was stunning like the Sun was
setting and I was thinking and that's
when in the moment I was like oh I
totally want to move here but I am NOT
in a place in my life financially where
I can give myself the life I would need
to live in Malibu yeah that's what we
were discussed we need to work hard play
hard here for you know five more years
and then finally take the plunge yeah I
just feel like for Theo's mental health
Malibu is the place for him yeah oh I
mean and then the craziest almost the
most Bashar as re-edition ancestors
would say meant to be thing happened on
the way home which by the way we flew
home on a Saturday which was so lovely I
loved having the day home on Sunday
before coming back to work on Monday but
we were in the Delta Sky Lounge which
was spectacular love Mia Delta Sky
Lounge and I said to Jackie I said I'm
gonna pee and don't get on the plane so
I pee and as I'm leaving the bathroom I
see this very refined lovely older
blonde woman she was beautiful and she
had a cavalier and it was the same
coloring as Sofia which we call him a
Blenheim and of course I was immediately
drawn and I see Cavaliers not a lot not
as much as I would like to but a good
amount and I never think that they're
even remotely as cute as Theo and
they're not always the
colouring there's tricolor there's
there's tons of different types of
coloring and I think that Theo's
coloring is the most beautiful which is
why I chose him when I got him so this
dog was so cute and I went up and I was
like what's his name
Lissa Lowe and I'm like his name was
Lancelot and I'm like wow that's
literate and I was just expecting like
Rex yeah no Lancelot and I was like oh
my god lives oh he French
Tigs and he was on our flight and she
was sitting one row behind us and we
literally stared at him I have a broken
neck because my neck was grained that's
a good boy it seems like flying with a
pup is literally the dream she went up
to go to the bathroom we were thinking
like what is she gonna do with Lance
while she's in the bathroom she planned
on taking lambs with her while she was
in line for the bathroom we were like
you wanna watch - watch Lance like so
you can pee in peace and she was like
yes what an exam basis now with Lance
she plops Lance down on our laps and we
just had like a few moments of pure
bliss with Gio's cousin it was making me
so happy I usually don't fall in love
with other dogs obviously I'm an animal
lover but to mean all animals are gross
except for Theo
totally and I just can't imagine like
having someone slobber on me and like
thinking it's cute but Lancelot was like
licking me and I was like he was clean
and like his mom was very like you know
elegant and I didn't think he was gross
ya know he did send Theo his regards but
sometimes I've like pet a dog and then
like literally looked at my hand and
it's like gray I can't stop it's worth
it sometimes he's worth it some people
keep their dogs like really [ __ ]
nasty
Lance was worth it yeah the whole trip
was great I'm happy to be back we have
such a busy week we've gotta get Lance
on the toes totally I think she also
told me in his origins we're from North
Carolina which is a favorite place of
mine Charlotte right I do think that he
has some fishermen running through his
blood and also I'm pretty sure they went
to camp together he was saying that he
knew Theo from back in the day she was
geography is a powerful force cavalier
geography we have such an exciting show
this week I mean shows this week we have
tons of guests Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday and Friday so make sure you're
watching live you guys YouTube it's
sliced way it's premium stuff and we
just have lots to discuss we got a new
Bachelorette Shahs of Sunset was on last
night I binge watch the trials of
Gabriele Fernandez and I'm here to tell
everyone what they need to know so that
they don't have to watch it because it's
so painful it looks too sad I watched a
trailer and I was just like I can't do
this to myself on a Sunday instead I
caught up on
colonel by the way it's poppin' I'm just
over it I know that you are but like I
love batching riverdale I probably watch
like six episodes what's your about
dynasty and you get so many answers at
once and then it was like still not
enough cuz we're finally getting
somewhere and even though you know they
have like this some stupid stuff that
goes on just the Goblin the court know
the goblins are gone Gorgo Gorga oh now
it's like gargoyle preppy school drama
because like John had goes to a fancy
private school and the kids they're like
hey you got a scholarship because it was
right and of course he did yeah and it's
just like there are just some moments
that it's just like this is why the show
is everything in the sort Katie Keene
was on one episode I'm so Katie came in
the air for Katie came in the air by the
way we would look he saw like lots of
celebs when we weren't like just we saw
when we were walking out of Nobu we saw
Cheryl from her and then we all saw
Diane Warren waiting for a table oh yes
she did I think she like looks me up and
down
did she yeah I guess I looked you were
looking fabulous I guess who else did we
see she was jealous of my Rafi's
honestly probably she would have loved
Rafi's well then should we jump in
because you know today's episode is
brought to you by Rafi's you guys this
weekend was barks me and I brought these
I wore my rock these on the plane which
if you ever are wearing a different pair
of shoes in the plane you're doing it
wrong and getting my own sister and then
I wore them to Nobu Malibu they were so
the vibe like I just love catching a
vibe in my Rafi's so true so do you
think it's I mean I guess it is time cuz
there's no time like the present to just
rave on Rafi's it's time for the past
five stories that you need to know yes
you Theo before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast and while
that's true you mentioned it before but
today's episode is brought to you by rob
these they're the perfect everyday shoes
for life on the go they're stylish and
comfortable and they go with everything
from yoga pants pants to dresses and
skirts whether you're going to Nobu
Malibu Malibu or just going to the
laundromat rob these come in an
ever-changing array of colors prints and
patterns and they're available in a
range of styles like sneakers loafers
points and more they launch new colors
and patterns every few weeks and they
sell out constantly they're playful
designs add fun pops of color and perk
up every outfit while still looking
polished professional and refined
they're seamlessly knit using thread
made from plastic water bottles so
they're ultra comfortable as soon as you
slip them on there right that's right
there's zero break-in period in these
shoes plus they always come with free
shipping returns and exchanges no risk
no
worries no reason not to try it'll blow
your mind that they're made from
repurposed plastic water bottles in fact
Rafi's has diverted over 35 million
water bottles to land from landfills
already so you can feel good knowing
you're looking fly but then you're also
quietly saving the earth and their
washing machine safe which is the
craziest thing the fact that all shoes
aren't is discover is disappointing
yeah I'm looking forward to watching
mine because honestly I was barefoot in
the airport and then I put my Rossi's
back on and now I have to like wash my
Rafi's but imagine if they weren't
machine washable like what would you do
go to Rafi's comm ro t hy s comm slash
toast to get your new favorite flats
check out all the amazing styles
available right now at roth is calm
slash toast comfort style and
sustainability these are the shoes
you've been waiting for
head to brought these calm / toast today
love it sign on get comfortable cute
shoes for spring spring / summer that
don't give you blisters you guys I think
I need to be the face of brothy he's
like I know I think gonna be doing the
foot of real thing I see Sochi my feet
are nothing of the sort I feel so
strongly about this brand and I'm so
glad that we get to share with me wish
you had invested I think that's my next
big move like invest ten dollars in the
company you can do that with Robin Hood
this show that's true no kidding it's
brought to you by brought these okay
first story it's what everyone's talking
about this morning it has been announced
that the next Bachelorette is Claire
Crawley I just want to say before we
dive into our thoughts on this news
once again the toasters new at first it
was posted in the spoiled toasted rows
then reality she picked that up he said
I haven't heard this anywhere but this
is something that's going around and it
was just like completely true yeah of
course we are this for DD we are the
pulse of everything like if you're not a
chose to like what are you doing now
what are you doing I seem to the show
right what are you doing we we discussed
last week about how we had heard that
this was a possibility and if it was the
truth we're fine with it because we're
not gonna watch and I felt like I was
really sure about how I felt about this
until it actually was announced and I
feel as though my opinion has changed
slightly like I don't think that this
was the worst choice in the world I
think a lot of my frustration with the
show is the fact is due to the fact that
all these girls and guys who come on are
so immature like 23 year old girls like
twenty-eight-year-old guys like they're
just not really realistically at a place
in their life where they want to get
married and they see the impact of the
show and they just like the followers
and I just mastered the thirst monsters
and I just think that having an older
woman she's 38 you'll have guys in their
30s and maybe in their forties like I
don't think that this is the worst thing
in the world I don't I don't know I just
I feel like I've really changed my mind
about it I think that this just is not
not bad at all and it's just weird
because I feel like we live in two
versions of The Bachelor one where they
play into like all the thirst monster
they've revolved come on as like a date
but then there's also like weirdly a lot
of true love that happens like Sean Lowe
and cat like there's there's real love
there but it's it's two different shows
to me and some seasons are one version
of the show and some season I feel like
we haven't had a real season like that
since like Lauren and Arie so I think
every few years they have to throw in
someone who they think is actually real
and not just looking to thirst out so I
changed my mind
I don't know if I'm gonna watch just
because she's not looking to thirst out
but this is like her fifth stint it's
her fourth stick television looking for
love I don't she was runner-up she was
on bachelor in paradise why since she
got winter games winter games yeah um
okay so this is her fifth fourth she was
on Juan Pablo season she was bachelor in
paradise twice I think she was only done
once no she had the season where she was
dating Zach and then didn't by the way
Helen Owen is quaking that literally
who's dating Zach called her and then
she was on a season where she was dating
Jared hi bond for a second um people on
Twitter are saying it's her fourth time
okay I'm pretty no I'm just conflating
the two season the by the way I thought
she was on two seasons to what the
people on Twitter are saying it's one
but what about the season move she was
seating Jared hi bond can you look it up
okay people are just trying to like you
know just fudge your memory a little bit
no people are saying it was her fourth
time like why I mean in yeah I think
it's her fifth time to be honest that
doesn't bother me like that much I mean
Nick vile was on three times bother me
it's not a bother but I I didn't watch
Juan Pablos season but I did see her
matram heretics like I don't think you
can count Juan Pablos season like me as
she was the runner-up no but I'm but I
mean like he was not really like in it
but he was like you have to count it no
but I mean like I don't fault her for
not going on and not finding love
Pablo season like his season is regarded
as a joke good like she did kind of find
love she was the runner-up yeah but they
didn't end up together no I mean I think
that's from Paradise is more of a joke
than Juan Pablo season
agreed but Juan Pablos season like I
don't consider it like a fair shot at
love he was nuts no he wasn't did you
watch it yeah really yeah how was he
nuts he was just crazy and he was rude
to everyone I don't know
well Aggies don't I don't hate this I
don't hate I don't hate it either I
don't really care I think it like in the
words of the Snatcher it's a weird flex
but okay yeah but I definitely
interesting choice yeah I just like I'm
who would you have preferred ooh I mean
honestly I really thought that Kelly or
Kelsey from the seasons I mean perfectly
suitable perfectly love it but then you
just get I mean they could cast older
like how old is Peter Peter weather yeah
I think he's 28 to me that's not old
enough for a man yeah I think at least
30 she's 38 so it will be an older more
maybe old and young right I think it'll
be like 35 to 45 which is crazy I don't
think we've ever had anyone in their 40s
no uh-uh you mean like contestant yeah
like we have I feel like Brad Womack oh
well this is also what's interesting is
that The Bachelor has now evolved a
little bit into like a thirst monster
show like the people who watch it aren't
like ogee fans they've been watching for
one of years and they don't know who
Claire is so it's again like these she's
just she was just I'm in Turkey and she
got engaged so not everyone I didn't
watch with dreams no but like the the
snatchers of the world they'd like the
people who are we don't watch every
season yeah I just think that like this
is really playing into like the two
different types of shows where it's like
their audience is like this thirst
monster audience who like wants to
revolve and the Cosmo trips but then
every now and then they'll do like an re
or their to a lauren which just seems so
weird because they play into the
thirstiness but then this is a very not
thirsty move no it's not it's like
they're trying to like regain the
legitimacy right but also like The
Bachelor inherently is thirsty it's a
television show yeah like but there's
levels like you're getting out of
control the season whoever covers the
lead and whoever the contestants are
like people are gonna follow them and
keep up with them and like the thirst
will be there so yeah I just think
there's varying levels of thirst like an
and to me is out of control you know
yeah she's actually like behaving lovely
she's not being by the way she's not so
she can't do anything until she's on
global city haven't even seen it yet ya
know geez I just see photo shoots of her
like not even from her modeling days
like she's just like in random beaches
being photographed and I just and like
moving to LA so I just think that like
she and brother she's a lovely girl
but she is really like the the point
here like she's what's wrong with the
franchise yeah so I'm not I don't know
if I'm gonna watch but I don't think
it's that terrible of an idea like to me
that's what I've been begging for from
The Bachelor is like someone who's and a
group of contestants who really is ready
like the love is blind people like some
of them were in their 30s like I that's
what I crave from a dating show but I
also crave a little of the thirst I
don't know I I might walk I'm not sure
about how I feel about watching it but I
don't hate the choice and but I do love
that like all the bachelors thirst
monsters who like just started watching
The Bachelor are like mad now and
they're like not gonna watch I love that
yeah that was like us when they made it
re and when they meet it Nick but now
we're just so evolved past that they
could really pick whoever I want
but by the way Emily were proved wrong
with Arie and with it yeah so I'm I'm
not just so quick to hate it now no I'm
not quick to hate it I'm happy for her
know that I am I'm sure like this I mean
it's the opportunity of a lifetime and
by the way and for a 38 year old single
girl like this is literally the dream
yes you're so lucky
yes so I'm excited to see what she does
with it and I think that because she's
in this position in her life like she
will do her absolute best to make it
work like she will take it seriously
yeah oh my god of course like she's won
pretty much takes it seriously while
they're there and then yeah but I mean
in the sense that like they handle it
like when Kaitlyn Bristowe was on like
she was cutthroat like if she was on a
date with someone and didn't enjoy her
time with them by like and some people
like Peter is just like waiting till the
very last minute to cut someone loose
like I think she will take it very
seriously in the sense like she will be
decisive and make those tough decisions
and I actually think like she might be
really good at it again not sure if I'm
gonna watch it but I think she'll be
good yeah I got in the mood to like like
not with you but just in general like
she just got engaged to someone from
winner like it just doesn't go was
Winter Games two years ago
not that she's not ready to be in a
relationship but like she had so many
chances like on these different
platforms she couldn't make it well you
could look at it that way or you could
look at it it's like homegirl isn't
really trying to fall in love but like
you know she just can't get it right
yeah like there's different ways of
looking at it there there's different
ways of looking at it overall I like her
I like her energy and her spirit I
didn't like her on bachelor in paradise
I thought she was so annoying me neither
no I'm trying better I'm trying to be
optimistic like they edit everyone like
if they edit people who I just like and
make me like them like I think that
they're just potential here I'm just
trying to be positive you know we gotta
stop talking so negatively about
everyone yeah we do have to and so we're
trying to see the positive I do think
that it should have been the snatchler
if it was my choice worse but it's not
the snatchler then Claire and there also
were like a lot of other good choices
but yeah you know I think maybe as Kelly
it could be a Claire in a few years you
know they'll bring her back because she
was really really what well liked but
the whole thing that happened with her
know if I had been on The Bachelor four
times and or one of the shows and like
had just been spun out like got engaged
I would just be so unbelievably over it
you know I can't imagine Kelly like I
feel like even if they asked her now she
would have said yes but like
trepidatious Li in four years for me
that's like a medicine like she said on
her Instagram like she would not take
the job like she would really really
have to seriously think about it yeah
because she's been on one season and two
paradises and like it's a lot and it
weighs heavy on your soul and you have
to leave home for so long so I do agree
like who at this point in Claire's
position would even want to be it yeah
it's just again it's an opportunity of a
lifetime it is but it's like she's been
in this cycle for six years now and now
it's like hitting the restart and she's
gonna go so like it's just it's tiring I
think it must I mean it's like everyone
in their opinions and I just can't I
feel like when you're younger you it's
also exciting you know when you're like
the Hana hands of the world but then
like once you come out on the other side
and you're like yeah or like you're 38
and maybe you're now like equipped for
like people judging you and making
opinions on you because you don't care
because you're 38 and like you're sure
of yourself yeah all I'm saying is that
I'm not as mad as I thought it would be
no I wasn't planning on being mad I just
I just was curious in the choice because
they just show the direction that the
producers want to take the show
I'm glad that they're choosing the route
real mature love as opposed to real
mature thirst oh and I think that the
type of people we will get cast for the
show
are much more the speed I'm hoping for
in my next Bachelor maybe someone who's
35 mm-hmm you know yes um okay next up
another batch related story but so sad
Tyler Cameron's mother Andrea Cameron
has died after quote a family emergency
so saddleman Tyler Cameron's mom has
died after being rushed to the hospital
on Thursday Us Weekly reports friends of
Andrea's have also posted on social
media mourning her death the news comes
days after days after Tyler cancelled
his appearance on Friday's GMA asking
his friends to fans to pray for his
mother amid a family emergency
he had wrote on Twitter have to cancel
GMA group run tomorrow family emergency
please pray for my mom and my family
when I was so sad he's so sad so it's
obviously quite sudden I can't stop
thinking about it
like really feeling for him I don't
think yeah because I feel like obviously
we lost a parent very suddenly but when
you're younger you don't realize the
magnitude of it and it kind of shields
you from your own pain also if you learn
anything from the movie room it's that
kids are actually a lot more like
adaptable and easier to bounce back than
an adult I think that actually going
through grief as an adult is way harder
than if it happens to you as a kid it's
obviously sadder because as a kid you
don't get that time with your parent but
there's pros and cons but it comes just
a fact of your life
yes opposed to like you've lived your
life and now everything is changed
absolutely like this is like my like I
just feel so when something tragic
happens to as a kid I think you're more
than likely to cope with it in a
healthier way or like in an easier way
then when it happens to you as an adult
I firmly believe that and then in the
movie room confirm that for me cus like
Jacob Tremblay was fine while like brie
Larson was like overdosing in the
bathroom right yeah I guess it's similar
to the film yeah it is anytime I hang
out with CEO and he's has time wo I feel
like we're in room because you know is
Jacob Tremblay because he doesn't leave
my room sometimes his hair gets too long
yeah sometimes I roll him up in a carpet
and make Ben take him outside in a
pickup truck that movie was so [ __ ] up
so [ __ ] up and what's the [ __ ] up
part about it is that it's not in a true
story and it's like I got all of my like
stomach and knots
not a true story yeah well back to Tyler
truly genuinely like wishing him this is
just like there's no there's no nothing
you could say like make someone feel
better you know so just truly wishing
him the best wishing him his mama so
cute so cute and like I didn't watch his
season but I'd imagine like his
hometowns were like so sweet and she was
always responding like on social media
like about him and just ah I really I'm
so sad about this so I have to yeah okay
next up some royal news because um
because Megan Megan Megan Merkel is
eating telly harvester breakfast
somebody she would totally daily harvest
for breakfast I know she was - allegedly
we're all overbooked over stimulated and
constantly running on empty for us were
always rushing to produce episodes we
barely have enough time to eat complete
meals let alone prepare healthy ones but
being busy doesn't mean you have to
resort to takeout or overly processed
food that's why we love to early harvest
they deliver the food you want to eat
but don't have time to make right to
your door they make easy makes it easy
to eat more fruits and vegetables with
thoughtfully source chef crafted foods
that can be prepared in five minutes or
less they work directly with farms to
harvest organic fruits and vegetables at
their peak and then freeze them within
24 hours to lock in their nutrients
everything with daily harvest stays
fresh until you're ready to enjoy it
choose for more than 65 different
options like smoothies hearty soups
harvest bowls and overnight oats each
recipe takes one step to prepare with
room to make them your own
add your favorite milk to blend up a
smoothie or heat up a harvest bowl and
top it with an avocado or a fried egg
whether you're at home at your desk or
on the go
daily harvest is the easiest way to have
delicious and nutritious meals or snacks
go to daily harvest comm and enter the
promo code toast to get $25 off your
first box that's promo code toast for
$25 off your first box at daily harvest
com daily harvest com promo code toast
for $25 off your first box sorry you
were saying Megan Markel what'd she do
now she reportedly will attend the Met
Gala and erm exit I saw this in page six
she's in where page 6 is reporting that
she's going form exit to the met that's
crazy it's just weird that like what is
it two months in advance like we would
get public confirmation like who
released this um the Sun I believe no
Sun mean as in not Megan
Archy UK like gossip rag yes Megan has
been invited to rub shoulders with the
big names who flocked to the annual
fashion mash alongside british vogue
editor-in-chief
Edward n fo I mean we predicted that
this is where she would be I think this
is exactly where what she wanted give in
like this is the most a list event of
all time and now she's a full time a
Lister I'm really excited to see her
like rubbing elbows with Kim Kardashian
I hope she like make some really premium
friends and like we just have these
relationships going forward I just
finished the redheads book of the month
which is red white and royal blue and
it's like what would be the term I don't
know but it's like it's base the
character it's about it's about the
royal family and like the first family
in the White House and like it's very
similar to real life but it's all fake
characters and now I'm just like
thinking about the Royals more than ever
before and like how much I just love
these public engagements for them I
wonder who who shall wear you know cuz
you have to go with a designer so I just
wonder like who well it seems like she's
going with the British Vogue editor
in-chief so she probably will have her
pick of the litter oh that's true like a
table full of girls who are wearing the
same designer that mean she's like
elevated
yeah she'll definitely wear like a
female designer maybe Yvonne Shay again
they did her wedding I showed you like
something sustainable like she always
allocate money
yeah but still McCartney I feel like
dresses so many girls at the Met Gala
that like Megan Marco wants to be
standout like she is now she never in
her life did she think that she would a
be invited to the Met Gala and be be one
of the most famous people there so she's
not taking this lightly I imagine and I
do think that ever in her life she
imagined well you know and you don't get
to wear Megan Merkel's gotten by not
dreaming big right that's true you
really you really don't I'm really
excited for the Met Gala me to do these
at least the theme yet yes they did and
it was something big coming to gaarkhan
no not coming to a Tarkan not camp I
miss camp I wish every year I mean every
year is camp because it's like a campy
version of whatever the theme is but
that was a real Adium camp on camp yeah
I'm excited justice for Khloe Kardashian
I hope that Megan can get her plus one
know if Khloe Kardashian doesn't go to
the Met Gala this year like I'm truly
rioting in the streets like she works so
[ __ ] hard
totally she works in fashion did you see
that Kim and Kanye are and
aras they're doing Sunday service easy
show there Courtney is with Kim yes she
went to the Balenciaga show and there
was a photo of like Courtney in the same
photo with Anna Wintour and now I'm like
if Courtney gets invited to the Mecca
and Khloe doesn't if they all do I would
be so happy
but if Kourt I don't know seeing those
paparazzi pictures of them in their
latex outfits like on the streets of
Paris like actually made me a little bit
mad because Courtney's like always
poking fun at like how seriously Kim
takes all the fashions so seriously and
all the look so seriously and like she's
always making fun of her looks and like
like being mad at Kim for critiquing her
outfits and then it's like yeah you're
mad and you're whatever but now you're
like tagging along being so thirsty
sitting without a one tour like that
those pictures actually kind of Bob yeah
they wearing whatever like came had
discarded for the day right from know
but wearing wearing something custom
because they sent Kim something it's
like all right I guess Wilson Courtney
something to yeah no it really it cuz on
the show they've beefed so hard but
always about the fashion they're always
together that's what we've spoken about
that before yeah it's curious it is
curious and I think a lot a lot of
they're beefing always comes from
something having to do with clothing
like there's a lot of resentment there
is there is anyways I'm glad they're
getting along I love that I love it all
but I just I need to put this out there
like Khloe must be at the Met Gala this
year especially if Courtney's gonna be
there no no taking it's time for the
whole family like Rob to no no to be
honest like if I had it my way it would
be like Kylie and Kendall Kim Kris and
Chloe okay i if we had yes I understand
that but now like put yourself in their
shoes and like the fact that they're
family and they love each other and
imagine if that was our family and like
one sister wasn't invited to the mek oh
that wouldn't put a stain on the
mcauliffe for all of us if we were all
invited be so [ __ ] steamy and we
would have the best time I don't know
they seem like they're cutthroat like
they've all been going for the last
three years we threw out Courtney or
closer but like imagine they come from
being like the first family of reality
TV where they thought they would never
be invited to an event like this ever to
then being every single one of them is
invited like that would be iconic it is
time and crazy to think that Khloe
Kardashian and Kourtney Kardashian have
never been to the Met Gala when they are
arguably yes they're part of the most
famous family but they themselves are
also some of the most famous people in
the world yeah and I just think like
their version of like skini vibes would
be at a peak if the entire family wasn't
by
like as a consumer that's what I want to
see yeah I mean I just feel like they
would all take a minivan from the mark
no I mean they went separately last time
Kendall and Kylie went together and then
Kim went by herself but I feel like if
the whole family was invited like they
would get an RV yeah we would go
together but they showed up in an RV
that would be iconic
I never see the movie RV of course I
know it's your favorite movie it's
literally one of the best movies to me I
don't like movies where everything's
going wrong and they're like on a
journey and everything's going wrong
along the way like are we there yet okay
let me just explain in defense of the
movie RV no I like I mean I like the
movie I love Jojo I love Robin much Jojo
is the daughter and Robin Williams is
the dad and to be honest it's so funny
it better it doesn't get better and then
there's like a sync they sing route 66
at the end which is just so strange it's
a fantastic movie and I just think that
it's worth your time okay I knew I mean
I liked it it's funny I'm just saying
that's like my rule of thumb is I just
don't like movies where like you know
frustrating to watch car is going down
the hill and we can't stop it and then
the brakes don't work just like I can no
it's so funny they don't have their
chains it's so great I just hope that
the Kardashians roll up in an RV squad
deep I want everyone there you know I
even want the kids there I think that
North should be invited but I that would
be crazy she's old enough is there an
age is there anything I don't think
there was heavenly 15 year olds you know
yeah so you know what I watch this
weekend tell the boys I loved before -
what did you think about it thought it
was lovely yeah it wasn't like the best
movie I'd ever seen but it was good and
I disagreed with what you said about how
I mean me because you had status I
looked at it differently but you said
like the movie wasn't believable cuz you
could never like believe that John
Ambrose even had a chance against like
no it's Antonia
totally there were times where I was
like maybe Noah and Lara Jean are just
too different and John Ambrose is like
her kindred spirit I'm sorry in no world
would a girl pick John Ambrose over Noah
Centennial
yeah yeah I think that was just not
believable like I wish they had gotten
two people on the same level in terms of
looks that's all I'll say okay next up I
chose this story specifically for you
Claudia because it just has everything
that we've ever wanted another royal
story Prince Andrew reportedly led a
supermodel sit on the Queen's throne at
Buckingham Palace
Chuck you're probably like why do I care
about this
story who's the soprano Caprice from
ladies of London he didn't what if
you've never seen ladies of London
season 1 there is this batshit she was a
singer too she was no she's like a
supermodel she had a lingerie source she
was like a really she but she was in
American but she really became an icon
in the right right right and so oh my
god wait I don't believe you hear this
story okay
Prince Andrew long dubbed Randy Andy in
his homeland went on a series of dates
in 2000 with model Caprice Barret a
household name in the UK who recently
starred in the reality TV show Dancing
on Ice but and also popularly stare
starred on ladies of limited and she
also like had twins on the first season
it was so easy and she was just like she
was nuts yeah she was I can't believe
she only was lasted one season which yet
because things Caroline see I mean see
Mary made sure of that
no she okay consider she ultimately
ghosted the Prince because she quote
didn't fancy him friends told the Sun on
Sunday but not before she was odd to
take a keepsake while being wined and
dined in the palace he took her to
Buckingham Palace twice and on one
occasion she sat on the Queen's throne
she spotted a bowl she liked and asked
Andrew if she could steal it and mail it
to her mom she claims that he let her
and her mom loved it Caprice who also
dated rocker Rod Stewart always treated
her dates with Andrew as platonic the
source claims from her side there was no
chance of a snog she didn't fancy him
but as an American she was thoroughly
entertained at the notion he was part of
the royal family plus all the secretive
rendezvous although unnecessary we're a
great family dinner conversation point
to be honest I'd like truly respect to
like her walking away from Prince edge
or even though he's discussing like he's
still a prince no but I respect her like
going out with him like to tell her
friends but like I'll take a bowl for
her mom ultimately not fancying him how
do we know this story to be true her
friends told it to the Sun and it's just
I don't even care what if it's you're
not wait their closeness made Prince
Harry who was just then a 16 year old
schoolboy jealous because quote he had
caprices calendar on his bedroom wall
just everything of this story is so
strange it has all the best elements
three seminars the ultimate element of
Jeffrey Epstein did not kill himself
yeah and the ultimate element of
everything in the world revolves around
Bravo
totally this is so crazy I saw this
headline and it just said supermodel and
I was like is that I mean we were just
talking about her recently we couldn't
remember her name yes telling her like
crazy and I was like is that the ladies
of London supermodel whose name we can't
remember and then nobody made it seem
like on the show like she was such a big
deal I wasn't buying it because she was
so bad she crazy on the show but now I
think this article proves that she is
truly everything of the sort when it
comes to you the UK yeah I just I love
it Wow shook worthy Caprice eh yeah also
it's reminding me of the redheads real
book of the month because this it's just
you guys if you haven't read it yet read
it I started on the plane back Saturday
I finished yesterday it's a really quick
read it's a really great story I'm
really excited to talk about it on the
show because like there's stuff I loved
about it some stuff that I was just like
in the beginning I was like do I like
this book but then ultimately pulls out
you guys oh so if you haven't subscribed
to Margaret Cho sips new show please do
so caviar dreams tuna fish budget
available on iTunes Spotify and anywhere
you can listen to podcasts love it okay
fifth and final story a little TV news
bittersweet Judge Judy will be ending
after 25 season Oh Judy Scheindlin says
this is the first I'm hearing however
she has a new show Judy Justice in the
works this is a confusing story but
ultimately um Judge Judy is coming to an
end after 25 seasons host Judy
Scheindlin says at the same event the
best flex of our lifetime was a Judy
Scheindlin diss Jewish and she's the
highest-paid woman on television at the
same time she isn't ready to hang up her
gavel just yet the syndicated court Show
host appears on Mondays The Ellen
DeGeneres Show where she told Ellen that
2022 21 season of Judge Judy will be its
last the Hollywood kollywood Reporter
confirm that Judge Judy will end
production after next season which will
be the show's 25th season on the air she
says I've had a 25 year long marriage
with CBS and it's been successful next
year will be our 25th season Silver
Anniversary and CBS sort of felt I think
they wanted optimally to utilize the
repeats of my program because now they
have 25 years of reruns so what they
decided to do was sell a couple of years
worth of reruns but I'm not tired so
Judy justice will be coming out a year
later well she's making so much money
cuz now so someone bought her old
episodes till I syndicate that I'm right
channels and that's where the money is
the syndication so she has 25 years of
syndication I mean she is just an icon I
can't believe that she still wants to
work because she's like you know she's
of a certain age she's of retirement age
she's so rich he must have over 100
million dollars in the bank so like go
to sleep you know no but here's the
thing like once you have that justice
bug it's just like you can never stop
serving it up yeah and by the way once
you have your gavel up it's very hard to
put a feel like every once in a while we
serve up justice on the show and he just
like feels so good - dick ting it's
addicting and she gets to do that every
single day I guess that's true he gets
to bring in the dancing lobsters I also
like as a woman as a human what more
could you want
I love that she's also at a place in her
life where she's like so famous but also
not famous
that like she has an announcement to
make it she goes on Ellen you know yeah
she's a Kardashian essentially you see
like get you a lawyer who could use not
a lawyer she's a judge Oh
but didn't she probably had to go to
loss yeah I'm sure she could probably
get you a judge who could do both yeah
she does it all you know if you ever
watched an episode of Judge Judy she's
[ __ ] cutthroat she has no time for
anyone's [ __ ] and she really she
sees a justice system from an
interesting POV and that's all we can
ask for it from a judge I have a new
respect for POVs ever since tick tock oh
my god I find this POV videos on takes
out to be infuriatingly they crazy yeah
smart
I see like the dumbest cringy swans like
POV you got the doors of heaven if you
see an aborted baby like oh my kids are
crazy stop oh my god and then they're
like welcome to Wonderland it's just out
of control oh my god okay well those are
the fast eye stories that you needed to
know I feel better having known them
especially that Capri sat on the Queen's
throne I thought you were gonna say like
naked
no no but like that's crazy you just be
skulking around the palace I mean he
obviously is a crazy man have you ever
um
sat on the Iron Throne no but I know
that you guys did I did they had like a
museum a few years ago at somewhere and
I'm toast their own which is just as if
not more prestigious now I have a lot of
TV to recap i watch those have sunset
last night and I watch the trials of
Gabriele Fernandez and I also watched
unbelievable that I would like to talk
about so our TV recap segment is coming
up and it's brought to you by the one
and only cent bird have you ever gone up
to someone and asked you smell amazing
what perfume you're wearing
cent is the most powerful since you have
a smoke can bring out a flood of
memories influence your mood and of
course enhance her natural style
well while you're looking at that
signature for that signature scent that
will make you stand out and keep the
memory of you lingering on your taste
can be expensive and buying a full
bottle of perfume anytime you want to
try something new can be hit or miss
with scent bird you can have a great
taste and mix up your fragrance routine
without breaking the bank
whether it's Tom Ford Gucci or Versace
sent bird comms keeps you smiling
smelling good month after month and then
subsequently smiling because they smell
so good
Archer to LA was very much tempered on
but sponsored by Sen bird I had my
Bulgari with me and did you see me
spritzing it additional time I just like
I feel like people in LA smell smell
good and I didn't wanna also Bulgari is
like so elegant
yeah I didn't want to stink up the town
so Sanford is a luxury fragrance
subscription service for perfumes and
colognes with more than 600 designer
brands for you to choose from every
month
she's the perfume you want to try and
they'll send you a 30-day supply but if
you're not sure what type of Tseng
you're looking for you can sort and find
your new fragrance by brand style
occasion season and more plus they now
carry products from other categories
like skincare wellness and makeup brands
like Aparri glam glow glow recipe tart
and so many others and with an exclusive
offer just for our listeners you can get
30% off your first one today that's only
10 dollars for your first fragrance
go-to scent bird dot-com / steen and use
the promo code 16 for 30% off your first
month that's ste and again that's scen
t-bird dot-com / Steen - sign up and use
our promo code scene to try your first
perfume or cologne for just $10 Dinah's
smell amazing okay that felt good so the
truck the trials of Gabriele Fernandez
is a story that I guess had happened in
2011 or she doesn't 13 somewhere around
then I don't remember hearing about it
usually like those national news stories
like people get so obsessed with true
crime I hadn't heard about it and the
story itself is just horrible like it's
cute very cute kid born into a
piece-of-shit mom literally that's the
definition of a piece of [ __ ] gave him
up instantly to her brother who was this
really wonderful gay he was in a gay
couple they took the kid in for the
first like 6 years of his life he had
such a good life like they loved him and
then some [ __ ] in the family made a
baseless accusation that the the gay
uncle's were sexually abusing the kid
absolutely unfounded really those
allegations to me were based in pure
homophobia like they there was no
inclination and they had other family
members being like we didn't believe
that yeah so then the kid ended up with
the grandparents who were questionable
but not not the best but not the worst
and he for the it made me feel happy to
know like for the first seven years of
his life like he was happy and he was
loved and then the kid for the last
eight months of his life ended up with
his mom and her live-in boyfriend
Isidora Giri also a colossal piece of
[ __ ] and for the eight months that he
lived with this fit with his biological
family and their two siblings just him
he was abused non-stop like burning
cigarettes on him made him sleep in a
cabinet with a sock in his mouth
handcuffed to the cabinet closed eating
what does he have to eat they didn't
feed him they've had him catnip okay I'm
sorry cat litter where the cat takes a
[ __ ]
non-stop abuse non-stop abuse physical
emotional mental verbal until one of his
beatings literally killed him and the
investigation was it was very clear from
the who did it and they put the mom and
the boyfriend on trial and they didn't
even say that they didn't do it but now
it was like the the whole trial was
whether or not it was intentional murder
like because it was premeditated and he
had the intention to kill Gabriel he
could be eligible for capital punishment
like they tried to put him to death and
so you watch the whole trial of the
boyfriend who was really the physical
aggressor and the mom was like telling
him what to do but the mom got physical
too they ended up giving the boyfriend
the death sentence the documentary was
very well done in the sense that it got
a juror who looks like a toaster like
she was like young cute girl I was like
couldn't something and she was a toaster
they got a lot I think almost all the
jurors in the documentary was explaining
it was always eleven to one there was
this guy who just like wouldn't budge
whatever they sentence him to death he
still hasn't been killed which it's like
what what's eating for literally what
are you waiting for and then the mom
took the candy she got life in prison
and mom and I was just like she to me
what she did was worse and when some of
the siblings were describing the abuse
she they said that she was physical too
so like she was also involved in killing
him but she was also his mom so I think
what she did was worse but honestly I
think that life in prison is
worse than the death sentence um I think
it just it depends okay but the the the
huge part of the documenting was how
like the the system failed the kid
because there were many times where the
teacher noticed that he had black eyes
and cigarette burns and they shaved his
head and he had like bruises on his head
and she reported it and there's like a
there's a system in place so she can't
really do anything other than report it
and she reported it multiple times and
the first time Stephanie Rodriguez who
was the caseworker like went to the
house and said she didn't see anything
even though I don't know how you
couldn't see anything and then the next
two times the teacher reported it she
never heard back from the social worker
so why the case was so interesting was
that the city ended up suing for social
workers and threatened like to go to
jail um and the more you watch it at
first you're like yeah the system sucks
I put them in jail and then you get to
know these four social workers and to be
honest only one of them was responsible
the one who never returned the teachers
call like her boss is not responsible
you know what I mean I felt like it was
a stretch for sure to try and implicate
the social workers but like someone has
to be held responsible and then the the
documenting was a little boring cuz like
and it was important but they went into
just like so much of the bureaucracy
like all the departments and the you
know government contracts like it got
really boring in the weeds but obviously
necessary to show like that the system
is is not good and it's and it's corrupt
and it's failing kids because right
after the Gabriel case was finally put
to bed after four years two weeks later
another kid died literally the same
exact way in the same County so it's
like the the system is failing kids for
sure it was just like a little boring
and I wanted to see more of the trial
like know more about how you literally
come to kill your own kid I just think
like that's interesting I I don't need
to know about anyone let's take a quick
pause of the siren
okay so uh it was just a [ __ ]
terrible story and I think that the
documentary would have been interesting
regardless just because the story is so
horrible but I did find that just one
like a sin I have to critique obviously
from a cinematic point of view
I thought the documentary was actually
like not so well done and kind of boring
but nonetheless a crazy story and DCFS
in LA County can rot in jail rotten hell
that's all I'll say
and also SRA Gary and pearl who like she
was the devil like you see her and she
gave a statement at their sentencing
where they sentence him to death and her
to life in prison she said can I say
something so you're like wow like
finally remorse she didn't even cry
first of all and her steamin was so
vapid and shallow she was like I just
hope one day my kids can come to their
senses and come visit me in prison
and so the family member who reported
that the gay couple was abusing uh
Gabriel are they in prison no and what
was so crazy is that the family members
husband ended up getting deported to El
Salvador so they went to El Salvador and
this guy was so lovely he was just like
such a nice guy he was crying and he was
like literate like we had him for years
like we loved him like a son and I don't
believe for one second that they were
abusing him but not even first I think
you talk to the person who made the
allegation no but they talk to a lot of
family members like he had a lot of
cousins and whatever um who now are like
activists and they started like a whole
thing like justice for Gabriel um
and none of them thought that that they
were abusing him yeah it was such a such
a horrible story like and it really
ruined my day I couldn't sleep I'm just
thinking about the cabinet I can't I
can't the cabinet that's so sad okay
let's talk about jaws oh okay Shah's was
good I love when they go to Vegas
because like one thing is consistent
with Shantha sunset it's like they all
just always get [ __ ] up but not
because they think they have to like on
TV because they just enjoy like being
together and taking shots um it was an
interesting crew that girl Sarah who's
new who has some connection to are Kelly
yeah um and she brought her brother who
ended up hooking up a destiny and I
thought they were really cute together
but this girl Sarah like thinks but
she's too good for everyone that she
thinks Destiny's like trash and that her
brother's too good for destiny when like
honestly they were pretty huge yeah I
don't know why she like doesn't like
destiny cuz you know what she's like
quiet and refined like very traditional
because you immediately gravitate
towards Golnesa
super out there but she's just like has
her MBA unless she thinks that's what a
good person woman should be she's like
very traditional and she admits that and
Destiny's like kind of his free spirit
and she does her own thing and she hooks
up with guys and like who cares like
literally who cares they're just
different yeah I find her to be like
judgmental and I don't really like her I
don't like it either or at least like be
like a judgmental person but don't like
have one set of standards for one person
and then another agreed she obviously
just like doesn't like destiny right um
and Reza's had his like Sally Beauty
event and then they went to top
confident just looked so much fun back
home yeah soon back home Gigi all Dourif
looked really nice I think the Waldorf
is new in Vegas CB I oh maybe we should
stay there maybe yeah back home Gigi was
getting an implant implanted with her
IVF um we know now that she was pregnant
so I think that this particular round
was successful but her mom was in her
house before like making her pineapple
juice and then driving her and she was
literally being so [ __ ] returned ah
I'm like four sob people who yell at
their moms are just animals like I just
I cannot relate to you on any sort of
level but people who do it on TV or even
more crazy like yeah I think of driving
was crazy
of course like her mom was driving
that's like the way she was speaking to
her mom like and it was just obvious
that she was so comfortable speaking to
her mom that way and her mom didn't even
flinch like I was shook like when you
when you were a kid and like a kid
started like talking back to her mom you
would be like oh my god yeah and we're
adults now like you supposed to know
better and now as an adult and when
you're a kid you're like oh my god you
can do that and now as an adult it's
like oh my God why would do that would
do that yeah it was really shocking and
it was more than once it was on the way
there and on the way back I'm like okay
I'm sure the mom is in a great driver
but like relax yeah just you should like
take a cab you would know that just
drive yourself I don't know I I love
gold I said so much and I'm so like I'm
I'm so proud of her for like knowing
exactly what she wants in doing whatever
it takes to going and getting in it's
repressive pregnant now like I'm just I
love this journey for her yeah it's
really interesting to see her character
arc over the last eight years going from
being a nut job like wielding knives to
now just like settling down and doing
like having a kid on her own I think
that's so impressive yeah MJ MJ is still
at home she's like pretty much bedridden
and um just talking about what's going
on with Reza and she's talking about it
with Tommy and to me I don't know what
happens but it really seems like Reza
had no idea how serious of a condition
she was in because he keeps just like
talking about it like it's not a big
deal and and he wasn't there and he
didn't go to the hospital which makes me
think he still didn't even know how bad
it was like
him he just thinks like oh you have a
baby you go to ICU like it's not normal
but then when him and Mike were eating
at that kosher restaurant and he's
telling Mike that MJ lost her uterus and
then the rabbit urine Mike is literally
praying for MJ when she's already had
her baby like I do think that you don't
pray that maybe maybe to get better when
you don't think their condition is that
serious that's true that's true it's
just so uncharacteristic of residence
such a bad friend yeah I think that like
his defense of his husband is blinding
him to like what's right yeah and I can
respect that of course but how
frustrating is Adam I mean I can't he's
the worst
I finally have caught up on shahs and
he's the what the whoa yeah no he's the
reason for all this strife and I do
agree in the sense that how Reza's
acting is so uncharacteristic like he's
really whatever you want to say about
him over the last eight years he's never
not been a good friend especially - MJ
who like is really his like heart and
soul and his ride-or-die
so he's acting so out of character and
it definitely is something to do with
the fact that he just feels like he has
to defend his husband when his husband
is being indefensible I know but it's
his husband like that's what you have to
do yeah you know and I it's a tough
position for him to be in but that's
like if you're not gonna defend your
husband then your husband the weirdest
part of the episode was the very strange
argument that escalated very quickly
between Mike and Nima did you see it Oh
many I was at first of all I hate Nima
I hated him since his first season last
season I knew he was trouble and to me
he's so transparent like I just despise
him and the conversation that he had
with Mike was just like an innocent
conversation that all of a sudden he
started saying this most evil [ __ ] like
out of nowhere all in all Mike was
saying was that I think you're leading
Erica on like she's living in your
apartment you're working together like
there's definitely some weirdness yeah
why should I listen to anything you say
you're the most dishonorable guy I've
ever met you cheat on everyone why the
[ __ ] would Polina like you like why
would this girl like you like he just
went so below the belt and he wasn't
even triggered by anything what what
Mike said was not crazy no was not crazy
at all also like NEMA doesn't represent
his relationship with Erica properly
because if he did then Mike would
realize that she's not off because I
said I would never end up she's not
interested obviously Nima doesn't tell
that part of the story because he didn't
hear that part because he doesn't care
like he only hears himself totally and
also the fact that Nima said that about
Mike went in the entire time that name
is
the show and had a friendship with Mike
Mike has been an honorable person right
so long as a Nima's known Mike he
doesn't he can talk about something
happens as you watch this show way too
much before he got on it Jackie I
totally agree and that's how I thought
about in the first season and I just
don't like him and now we like mainly
like made money from reality she being
like got into apartment and new teeth
and like thinks he's hot [ __ ] yeah but
you know why he's nothing of the sort
he's the definition actually of nothing
of the sort
I literally still have a bit nice like a
pain in my stomach from Gabriel oh I
just want to say one more thing about
the documentary that's not I think you
see I can't take it they had a million
people
jurors lawyers district attorneys they
had that they had one of the social
workers who got sued like they had
everyone and absolutely everyone
including his family that remembers
called him Gabriel this one reporter she
was on the whole documentary every
single episode kept calling him got me
out and it was bothering me so much okay
if you're gonna be if you're related to
him like that's obviously how you should
refer to him because that's obviously
his name but like literally this person
who didn't know him is calling him
Gabrielle and it was bothering me so
much like she was saying with the accent
and it's like everyone's Halim Gabriel
like his family his cousin's like
lawyers and you're calling Gabrielle it
bothered me so much
and she was literally the star of the
documentary she had the most information
oh wow terrible um and I also watched
unbelievable which I know people watched
like years ago years ago it was
exceptional like so so good I just mean
snitch start watching it it was
basically just like a really really long
episode of SVU and to me I love to and
that girl who you told me that she was
in it the girlfriend book-smart I don't
know her name and forgive me because
she's gonna be a household name she's
the most amazing actress like I thought
she was great in book smart and this was
like a totally different role dramatic
thriller and she was excellent as well
so she has a really bright future I
think she's gonna be a star oh sweet
well while you were watching that I
caught up on Siesta Key also I'm so
behind I just say like overarching lis
justice for Juliet I don't care that
she's been getting physical because Juan
Chloe threw for hands first she didn't
she did and second Alex and his
girlfriend or whatever we're completely
gaslighting her by the pool and all she
did was throw Alex in the pool but you
know what I stand by Marge when she did
it and I stand by Juliet husbands in the
pool the ripping of the bikini like
wasn't her best moment but she was being
completely gas-lit lied about and I just
like I'd completely defend her I feel so
terribly for her do you know what's
going on with Chloe Troutman know she
was tweeting like
something had happened and like a bunch
of her friends reached out I had no idea
maybe think we should break up with her
boyfriend but they're like so it's like
solid smell it's actually just posted
with me neither I think I saw her tweet
it she said that she texted like four
friends that she wasn't okay and only
one called I think she was just running
through it without friendship oh I made
it seem like it was something terrible
okay I hope not
yeah I love those girls and I really
like Juliet I'm super behind and it will
eventually catch up and people have been
wanting us to recap CS Turkey but at the
end of the day I don't even need to see
the episode - no justice for Juliet like
truly truly truly she's it's just like
that feeling of being on the outs with
your friends when everyone thinks you're
a liar like she's literally like
cancelled and her friend group and she
has to like you know make amends with
everyone and humble pie yeah and it's
just like it's she's getting a uh she's
better than that yeah she is
um we have such a busy schedule who's on
tomorrow tomorrow we have diamond from
shark tank Wow shook okay I actually got
a new blazer that I was gonna wear today
and I was said I'm like I know Daymond
John is on the show this week where I
will save my blazer we have to wear
Blazers tomorrow he's coming up with a
new book which we have no choice but to
support you know an entrepreneur but
obviously I'm gonna get him down in this
chair and just ask him 1 million
questions about shark tank and what it's
like to be just like so rich and
powerful and what he thinks about all
the guest sharks and I'm gonna put a
card up on her Instagram later so please
give me like dynamic I want him to think
we're like impressive and smart and we
have to tell him that we saw like we've
been waiting Our Lives to like be in an
elevator with him so we could pitch the
morning shows you an elevator pitch and
then we got an elevator with him and we
were like soaking wet like drunk from
day drinking and on your bachelorette
party and we just didn't say anything
yeah so good times good times we have
tons of other guests to speak with that
will announce as become really good buds
I think a lot of you guys are gonna be
particularly excited about our guests on
Wednesday
oh and Thursday oh and Friday so that's
all she wrote correct all she wrote I
think you also think it was ending this
episode on a fart and we just he knew we
have no choice but to thank you so much
for listening to the morning tosai
millennial Morning Show where we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube we're also available as
podcasts anywhere podcasts we found so
it's about if I can sit your public we
knew I already know cashbox
oh the places so every you listen to
podcast find us the morning shows I
leave a review a subscription about I
don't know maybe a comment about a
beautiful stunning and smart we all read
that whatever that would work yeah also
subscribe to us on YouTube give this
video a thumbs
youtube.com slash in the morning trust
me love you guys so much have an amazing
day we will see you tomorrow with
Daymond John